in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Chad
and Tara are with us hey guys how are
you hey
welcome welcome where're you guys from
we're from Charleston Illinois just
south of Champaign very cool well good
to have you thanks for coming down to do
your debt-free scream thank you and how
much debt have you paid off we've paid
off just over a hundred and thirteen
thousand dollars I love it about forty
four months
good job and I'm making what kind of
range of income during that time we were
at in between 78,000 and just finished
up at about eighty six thousand good
deal what do you guys do for a living
I'm actually a middle school system
principal and I work part-time as a
secretary at a church oh very good
very cool what kind of debt was the
hundred and thirteen well it was mostly
credit card debt and then we had two car
payments and we had a mortgage on a
rental house that we own Wow how long
have y'all been married ten years this
year how much was the credit card debt
of the one thirty about 65 about 65 and
where'd that come from anything in
particular great question one to me
trips to Target and Walmart and there it
goes yeah over and over and over again
over ten years of marriage yeah
$65,000 in credit card yeah Wow so tell
me your story of what happened forty
four months ago what was the wake-up
call and out of the journey unfold well
we we actually decided to take financial
piece at our church and we really
thought we had it figured out we thought
but what would it hurt to learn a little
bit more and boy were some cold water in
the face yeah we were and so you know we
just got got got in and buckled down and
really started tackling our debt we made
some decisions that you know despite the
fact we know you say sell the car sell
the car we we sold ourselves we're gonna
work extra hard just to make sure we
were able to keep our vehicles and just
buckle down and got the job done Wow
okay so you tore into it then it takes
you coming up on four years you've been
tearing into this that's a lot yeah I
mean you've been fighting this thing a
long
time yeah what was the hardest part for
you all well I think for me because we
did decide to keep our cars and not sell
it we trimmed down certain things like I
think yeah we have a family of four and
we live on $200 a month for groceries oh
yeah how coupons and sales and that well
they were a lot of macaroni and cheese
and hot dogs what kind of cars are these
we have a 2011 Sienna uh-huh and then we
have a 2009 saturn vue okay yeah you
were fighting hard to keep them I'm
selling it that's why I was asking yeah
yeah absolutely amazing Wow Wow
phenomenal very very well done so what
do you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is you paid off a hundred
and thirteen thousand dollars where it's
just hard work Dave really you know that
the key is sticking to your budget it's
so easy to go off of budget for for
little things that turn up to be big
things later on and I really think the
key is staying to the stick into the
budget doing it together making sure
you're on the same page
it is definitely key I know that sounds
so cliche but that's exactly what it
what it takes
oh there's a reason that we have cliches
because they're rooted in truth exactly
that's very good you know and one of the
things I know that that we we
experienced during this this journey was
the fact that we found much like you
said your marriage gets stronger as you
do these things together and you you you
just tackle some of these tough battles
together and as long as you have each
other by your side it really does
strengthen things along the way -
absolutely very fun well congratulations
you two
thank you very well done you're heroes
you took control of your life yeah I
didn't let someone else tell you it
couldn't be done
you didn't wait on someone else to come
along and fix it you took control and
you did it yeah very very well done
excellent job very cool stuff so we're
going to give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired right okay
that's the next step now yes to become
wealthy and the increase your giving and
increase your investing and there
you how to do that because that's the
next thing we're gonna scream about I
don't know what we're gonna scream I'm
about there or something we'll figure
out what you're gonna scream next but
this is a good stuff so you know Dave
too one of the things that we were FP
coordinators now since this we've had
three classes we just started smart
money smart kids class at our church
this past Sunday some thank you and it's
it's helped drive us seeing others
succeed as well with her with managing
their money but as great as any book is
to read really encourage people to get
engaged in a community and where they're
learning together and growing together
it's meant the world to us for all the
people that we've we've seen through the
process too it makes all the difference
in the world
it sure does the groups around that
thing and the discussions and the
encouragement that comes the occasional
wake-up call but mostly just the
encouragement that comes it's very very
cool stuff alright the kiddos names are
what in what ages Kaitlin is seven and
Paxton is going to be five next week
alright very cool good-looking young
people fun stuff alright Chad and Tara
Kaitlin and Paxton Champaign Illinois
area one hundred and thirteen thousand
dollars paid off in forty four months
making seventy eight to eighty six
thousand and no groceries count it down
let's hear a debt free scream ready
three two one
where to go you guys
very very very well done I love it I
love it I love it
congratulations hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind